let me be honest for a second i'm really
into gender equality i don't know about
you i'm into it
within reason
i'm kidding fully i'm fully into gender
equality but i am tired of girls getting
all the sexy halloween costumes have you
noticed that it's much more fun for the
ladies because they can really hoard up
for one night
and i i feel left out i want some sexy
sexy costumes from men so i can be i'm a
fella that likes to you know s sex it up
i didn't know what
that's my set i like to sex it up it's
not working so good for old painting uh
so what i did was i created a line of
costumes that i think women will find
very attractive for this year's sexy
halloween costumes for men
get ready to get moist
up first ladies and gentlemen we have
confident zombie
yeah
women love confidence and this
self-assured guy wants to take a bite
out of life
and your torso
thanks confident zombie
looking good baby
up next we have beowulf
he's a werewolf who's always there
look at him reliable dependent
even during a full moon this solid
dude's not going anywhere because he's
not a wolf boy
he's a wolf man
for your consideration a twist on an old
classic good with kids dracula
regular dracula is a creepy old bachelor
who lives alone in an empty castle
wearing capes to dinner
that's weird
but just add a kid to the costume all of
a sudden you're dad material
yeah
up next everybody one of my favorites
this is actual doctor
that's sure to do it for the ladies uh
dressing up like a doctor is fun sure
but really what you're telling women is
wouldn't it be crazy if i were smart and
successful lol
but sorry fellas this costume isn't sold
in stores they give it to you after
seven grueling years of med school
but it's worth it for all the butts you
get to put your finger in
and finally ladies and gentlemen it's
the toilet paper mummy who puts the seat
down and always replaces the roll by
putting it on the actual bar not just
placing it on top of the empty roll
this guy understands that it takes two
seconds to let your spouse know you give
a after you take
one this is one deuce you're not gonna
wanna drop
and that's sexy halloween costumes for
men everybody
you